again congratulations to you literally
to have them and thank you Jimmy Stewart
you know when a great star walks on the
screen he dominates it when Jimmy Cagney
walks on the screen he owns it he's held
the first mortgage for 20 years he's
done everything from a buck-and-wing to
Shakespeare
he's patrols a movie beat like no actor
of his time an Academy Award where
himself is about to make the award for
the best picture of 1949 Jimmy Cagney
ladies and gentlemen tonight we have
seen Hollywood at its Sunday best as
greater the temptation is to share in
the dignity of the evening and add to
the add a contribution of well deserve
superlatives about the only thing left
to say is meet the champion and the
nomination for the Best Picture of the
year are all the king's men are Robert
Ross in production Columbia battleground
metro-goldwyn-mayer
the heiress paramount a letter to three
wives 20th Century Fox and 12 o'clock
high 20th Century Fox
Yahoo please the winner all the king's
men Robert Hoffman Tommy OH Sir Robert
Roslin is coming to the stage to accept
the award for all the king's men great
picture starring two of our winners all
over the seasons Broderick Crawford the
best actor at Mercedes McCambridge the
best supporting actress here is mr.
rawson thanks very much I should thank
anyone I'd like to thank all of the
people who contributed to this picture
all over again and all of you thank you
again
Thank You Jimmy Cagney thank you and
congratulations Bob Ross thanks very
much all of you very very nice people
you've met the new royal family of
Hollywood may they reign mightily for a
year and a day bless you all
ladies and gentlemen so concludes the
22nd annual Academy Awards Show and it
rounds out our ABC country of this great
spectacle
we could put you late just once more for
you
havilland the best actor to Broderick
Crawford the best supporting actress
diversity's McCambridge the best
supporting actor Dean Jagger and the
best picture to all the king's men I
certainly want my stalwart cohorts
cohorts here this evening to say good
night to you at first of all here's miss
Eve Arden well thank you very much Ken
it was terribly exciting doing this
there was a lot of fun I only wish I
could have described some of the
beautiful gowns I saw tonight I was
ruling but it was a little difficult we
didn't quite have time enough now Ronnie
Regan wants to say good night yes you
know Kim you'll pardon a personal
reference sitting up here looking out
through this glass window has taken me
back to some years ago when I was a
radio sports person and this used to be
the stage of a big drilling football
game when you say the long blue shadows
are settling over the field the teams
have left
you'd give the statistics in the game
and I don't know of any game that I ever
broadcast there was any more exciting or
thrilling than this when once in awhile
Hollywood gets to show a world and a
world of detract in many cases that
we're a hard-working and a very serious
community and a fine industry made up of
very many fine generous people it's been
a pleasure to be here with you and a
pleasure to be on the air and
participate in this particular 22nd
annual award tonight